le cinéma maintenant avec notre invité
c'est philippe noiret je voulais
présenter dans les titres tout à l'heure
bonsoir philippe noiret et conçoit alors
vous êtes là parce qu'un nouveau de film
sort celui de bertrand tavernier qui
s'appelle la vie et rien d'autre mais
surtout si vous invitez c'est parce que
c'est votre centième film oui j'ai
vraiment le faire mais oui justement
très longtemps si la donne un coup de
vieux mais je réagi vivement dont on les
voit pas passer c'est comme le temps et
puis on va je vais aligner quelques
banalités comme d'habitude quand on
aborde ce sujet mais c'est vrai on ne se
rend pas compte que j'avais pas eu un
biographe attentif leur parler d'
attentionné et m'a dit et le film de
bertrand c'est le 100e alors alors dit
matt vous devez être content parce
qu'alors là les critiques sont
dithyrambiques oui oui oui j'ai vu par
exemple dans l'express je sais plus qui
écrivez ça philippe noiret qui est l'un
des plus grands acteurs du monde c'est
ça oui ça aussi moi oui c'était pas
temps non oui avoue rêver tout fait ça
on va se muer au curry non sur celle à
10 on vous pouvez attendre les
libérations sa délibération ils crachent
dessus depuis 15 ans la ben oui oui non
ça va c'est vraiment les seuls non non
ça fait tâche d'huile en ce moment mais
c'est pas grave je suis là je m'accroche
je vais encore faire sans et il faudra
qu'ils s'y habituent
on va reparler de vous bien sûr mais le
film quand même la vie je vous ai rien
dorémieux parler du cube bertrand
tavernier alors raconté un petit peu de
quoi il s'agit c'est une histoire c'est
une histoire d'amour qui se passe en
1920 après la guerre de 14 entre 1
militaire de carrière que j'interprète
qui est chargée de diriger le bureau de
recherche et d'identification des
militaires disparus car il ya eu trois
cent cinquante mille disparus en plus
d'un million six cent mille morts en
14-18 est aussi et est aussi de
retrouver et de retrouver aussi soldats
le soldat inconnu il est chargé de ne
pas de le retrouver mais d'en choisir un
qui soit comme disait la hiérarchie
militaire à l'époque surtout denis 1
bosch ni un angliche et surtout pas un
[ __ ]
ça aurait fait ça aurait fait désordre à
ce moment là alors c'est un problème
voilà comme quoi il ya à la fois et
c'est une histoire d'amour avec une
femme qui a perdu qui est dont le mari
est disparue et qui va de bureaux et de
grands bureaux et de pitau en hôpitaux
essayer d'avoir des traces de son mari
dix pages est un film anti militariste
non pas du tout c'est un film anti
guerre un de plus vous me direz c'est
tout le monde est contre la guerre mais
enfin là c'est un film sur la vie comme
le titre l'indiqué clavier rien d'autre
c'est un film qui est donc une histoire
d'amour qui se passe sur ce sur ce
terrain de ruines et de souffrance
d'après la guerre de 14 mai je vous
propose ensuite d'en voir un extrait
mais à lyon l'an dernier à gaillon
on a tout tenté pour jour j'avais fait
une 9,2 félicitations à vous chers avec
demande de permission exceptionnelle
merci
si vous aussi vous ressemblez des hommes
retour d'anthony
rassemblement
on fait ce que nous pouvions
parce que votre mii intercités c'était
pour toutes sortes de raisons
faudrait des semaines pour dégager
dégagez quoi d'ailleurs la boue et
dessins voilà un extrait de ce film
alors philippe noiret vous parliez tout
à l'heure de votre biographie parce
qu'effectivement à l'occasion de ce 100e
film il ya un monsieur qui s'appelle
dominique mallet qui a écrit un livre
sur route s'intitule en toute simplicité
philippe noiret oui barre et il a pensé
que c'était plus simple et en toute
simplicité il ya une préface de françois
mitterrand c'est un de vos amis
non non non oui c'est dominique mayega
écrit c'est pas une biographie c'est un
livre sur les 100 films auxquels j'ai
participés quoi et dominique maye est un
grand timide et comme tous les grands
timides il a des pulsions irrésistibles
comme ça il a été pris un peu de
mégalomanie et l'a demandé au président
de la république d'écrire une
introduction si ce n'est une préface et
celui ci a accepté après avoir dit qu'il
était un peu occupé par les élections
d'abord et ensuite par le sommet et mais
il l'a fait
bien évidemment j'ai été très touché et
par le geste et par les termes employés
je vais vous dire ce qui semble un peu
inquiétant dans votre cas sauf que vous
parliez tout à l'heure de libération
mais c'est justement jamais du mal de
vous suffit non c'est très très rare nom
soit de pong ses six matches de paris
mettant c'est inquiétant oui remarquez
c'est confortable d'un autre côté mais
non depuis l'accident pendant une
quinzaine d'années j'ai été tout à fait
toujours encensé puis le plus cinq ou
six ans une sas nuance c'est très bien
comme ça on dit beaucoup que je fais du
noir et souvent ça ça revient il vous
dit beaucoup que vous aimeriez être un
honnête homme et moi j'en ai une passion
vous êtes trop poli pour être honnête
sûrement oui je cache sûrement des
noirceurs 1 que seul mais intime
connaissent et savent il ya un très joli
mot excuse un jour je me parlait au
niveau de frais bogaert qui on disait ça
nous ennuie pas de jouer toujours des
rôle à la bogart et 10 est de toute
façon c'est moi qui les jouent mieux ce
que je trouve une très belle réponse
merci philippe noiret puisque vous êtes